Troy Brown Anthony Davis and LeBron
James 4.1 seconds remaining well they're
going to pin down for James
comes up top gets it James on the drive
gets in the paint layup missed it
and the game is over Lakers Furious they
thought he was fouled
excuse me and it's now overtime
LeBron James so upset
regulation is over we go to the
five-minute OT
foreign
ham looks at the officiating staff and
says terrible
wow clear foul on Tatum and there's
where you talked about the challenge
Jeff not having it after a successful
challenge right but they wouldn't be
able to challenge that anyway because
it's a non-call but
again this is exactly why replay was
instituted if we can't review that
then to me replay
serves no purpose in our game over time
is next
[Applause]